I love my child I love my mother so much
that I couldn't survive if anything
happened to them it's like you have some
serious thinking to do about that it's
like you really want to curse someone
with that kind of love do you I couldn't
live without you it's like my god get
away from me
really it's terrible that's the eatable
mother right that's like I'll forgive
you no matter what you do it's like
really you no matter what I do eh
you are not my friend that's for sure
not at all it's a horrible thing to do
to someone that's that's the witch in
the Hansel and Gretel story all
gingerbread and outside to the lost kid
inside you feed them candy and make them
fat and eat them right that's Hansel and
Gretel that's the eatable mother that's
one of Freud's major discoveries it gets
a major discovery it's like the
devouring force of love you want the
person to be able to stand on their own
and price you pay for that is that you
stand on your own it's like good to have
you around I'm glad you're here but if
if tragedies win and if and when tragedy
strikes either of us I hope that one of
us is standing when it blows past and
and that there's a harshness about that
that's unbelievably cruel because you
know you say well if my mother died I
could live well what kind of monster are
you exactly
death of your mother doesn't do you in
well turns out that being a monster is
the right thing so and that's a rough
thing to learn but it's necessary to
learn you know because it also makes you
you know at some point for example as
you get older mm-hmm
by the time you're in your mid-20s
something like that you should start
having a relationship with your parents
that's approximately one of peers and
you can tell if you have that so here's
a little trick you can use so you have
parents obviously they have friends you
probably care what your parents think I
would imagine do you care what their
friends think of you and answer that is
well not nearly as much and so then I
would say well why do you care what your
parents think of you then they're the
same people you know what I mean it's
just luck of the draw that you're
parents or someone else's kids friends
they don't think the same way about them
that you do that's where you see that
you have a projection right if by the
time you're 30 if what your parents
think of you matters more than what say
a random set of their friends think of
you then you've still got your parents
confused with with God that's one way of
looking at it you've still got them
confused with an archetype and you're
still a child and you might think well
it's pretty damn rude not to think about
what your parents think of you anymore
not to care it's like yeah it's kind of
rude but maybe you'll be useful for them
when they get old and that's a much
better form of caring it's like you're
going to be independent enough and
strong enough and and detached enough so
that when the taught when the when the
power dynamic shifts which it will that
you'll be the person that can carry
things forward well you can't do a
better thing for them than that right
that's the best of all possible outcomes
for your parents